okay so picture this for like 150
chapters we are all waiting for the
reveal of the final Navy Admiral the
mysterious and deadly green Bowl we
finally get his introduction at the end
of wano he's a badass he's smacking
people left and right he takes out king
and queen at the same time like it's
nothing he's pounding the scabbards like
a No Game No Life fan pounds his body
pillow and then he reveals a brand new
logia devil fruit and just when you
think he's about to curb stomp
momonosuke green ball just stops in his
tracks the man looks like he just
[ __ ] in his pants and he's paralyzed
why because the red-haired Menace Shanks
just pimp slapped him with a hockey
Blast from literally miles away shank
sends a telepathic message telling cream
bull to leave Luffy and the others alone
because they're still tired from
fighting kaido and big mom and this this
overpowered logia using Admiral who just
one shot at king and queen is like oh
Shanks no worries bro I don't want to
pick a fight with you guys and then he
leaves he leaves wano after defying
orders from his Superior officer just so
he could come to wano and kill some
Pirates green bull pieces out after one
hockey Blast from Big Daddy Shanks and
that is what we'll be talking about in
this video how a man with very little
actual screen time can have such an
earth-shattering impact on the story
Shanks is not who you think he is and I
don't just mean that he's actually a
Celestial Dragon who was found by Roger
on God Valley even though he totally is
Shanks is a phenomenon in the world of
one piece a war ending Admiral smacking
and Makino smashing Giga Chad in fact
this man is so epic that Oda might have
written himself into a corner with
shanks's character and that is about to
come into full focus in the final Arc of
One Piece now drop a like and sub for
Big Daddy Shanks and let's get into it
we meet Shanks in the very first chapter
of the story and he's literally the man
who inspires Luffy to become a pirate
without Shanks Luffy might have ended up
becoming a Marine like GARP always
wanted and the entire one-piece story
might have been like a police procedural
where detective Luffy solves Mysteries
with his grandpa but instead the red
hair Pirates decided to roll into town
and Shanks spent over a year hanging
around fuchsia Village and getting
serviced by Makino that is where Shanks
met Luffy that is where Luffy ended up
accidentally eating the devil fruit that
the Pirates stole from the world
government and that is where Shanks had
the ancient giant sized balls to tell
Luffy that he was too young to join his
crew even though Shanks himself was a
member of Rogers crew since he was an
actual toddler in diapers the first real
conflict we see Shanks engage in is when
he is blatantly disrespected by some
dirty Mountain Bandits who look like
they haven't showered in months like you
can tell these guys smell bad just by
looking at them the bandits are mad that
Shanks and his crew drank all the booze
at party's bar and Shanks being the nice
guy that he is offers the Bandit leader
higuma the last bottle higuma feels
insulted by the idea that a single
bottle of Grog could be enough for him
and his men so he breaks the bottle and
dumps it all over Shanks now at this
point in time Shanks is not yet a yonko
but he is already a notorious pirate
whose Bounty is far above higuma's small
PP Bounty of 8 million but instead of
cleaning the floor with higuma's Pepe Le
Pew looking face Shanks humbly
apologizes to Makino for the mess and
proceeds to pick up the pieces of broken
glass and that's not even all of it
higuma's like oh yeah you like cleaning
Bud here this will keep you busy for a
while and he uses his sword to smash a
bunch of other things and make an even
bigger mess meanwhile Shanks this epic
badass future yonko is sitting flat on
his ass lick her dripping all over him
while higuma smiles and holds his sword
like let's be real bro let's be honest
with ourselves higuma just money shot at
our boy in this scene the bandits then
leave while laughing and calling the red
hair Pirates cowards and you're thinking
man what are they gonna do now are they
gonna like wait for Nightfall then sneak
into the mountains all nice and slow
Ambush the bandits and then straight up
unleash the eclipse from berserk right
on top of them but no once the bandits
leave Shanks and his crewmates just
laugh they laugh and move on like
nothing happened and Luffy is pissed I
mean he looks up to Shanks and these
guys he wants to join their crew and now
some unwashed Mountain Bandit made them
all look like a bunch of Discord mods
but what Young Luffy sees as a sign of
weakness is actually a sign of strength
shame Banks doesn't think that getting
some booze spilled on you is a big deal
in the end no one got hurt so who cares
the only thing that might have gotten
bruised was shanks's ego but because
Shanks is confident enough in himself
and in his own abilities he doesn't need
to worry about a bruised ego better to
get a drink spilled on you and laugh
about it than get into a fight inside a
tightly packed bar where a bunch of
innocent people could get hurt hundreds
of chapters later Luffy and Zoro would
take a similar approach to Bellamy's
provocations inside a Tavern in Jaya so
for all his complaining about Shanks
being a coward Luffy eventually
completely adopts shanks's philosophy
it's just one of the many ways that
Luffy's life is shaped and influenced by
Big Daddy Shanks but back when he was
still a kid Luffy would go on to start a
fight with higuma and the mountain
Bandits after they insulted Shanks and
the red hair pirates in front of him
even though Luffy was personally
disappointed at how Shanks allowed
himself to be humiliated by the bandits
he still couldn't stand to hear higuma
in salt Shanks and and call him a coward
so Luffy lunged at the bandits and
demanded that they take what they said
back as a result he took a massive
beating from higuma but even a brutal
Beatdown wasn't enough to get young
Luffy to back off and he continued to
resist the bandits and to hurl insults
at them so much so that higuma decided
that Luffy must be killed as punishment
not even though Luffy is just a little
kid who's getting a public beating from
a bunch of scumbags with a bad body odor
no one in town had the strength to stand
up to them the townspeople of fuchsia
Village can only watch in anguish as
higuma prepares to take this little
kid's life with a saber luckily for
Luffy just before the bandits can
actually kill him Shanks and his crew
appear the bandits think that they'll
just be able to bully the Pirates again
like they did last time but that's where
they're wrong Shanks doesn't care if
some pungent lowlife insults him or
pours a drink on him or even spits on
him that doesn't actually hurt anyone so
who cares but Shanks will not stand by
while someone is hurting a friend of his
and for all their Mutual teasing Shanks
sees Luffy as his friend one of the
bandits points his gun and chanks his
head in an attempt to intimidate him and
get him to stand down but Shanks Just
Smiles and says that by pointing a gun
he is putting his life on the line
pointing guns is no joke and by pointing
one at someone you are putting that
person in imminent and Mortal danger
that means that the person you are
threatening is Justified in using lethal
Force against you in the very next panel
we see the consequences of this callous
Behavior without even batting an eye and
while still eating his chunk of meat
lucky Roo shoots the gun toting Bandit
and ends him on the spot and I don't
mean in Minecraft he ends the Bandit for
real which shocks everyone and drives
home one very important Point even
though these Pirates are easy going and
carefree most of the time and even
though though they are willing to put up
with Petty insults without reacting when
things get serious the red hair Pirates
don't play around these guys are
professional badasses these guys are
powerful Pirates and getting on their
bad side is a very bad idea higumai is
of course way too stupid to understand
his own predicament so he tells his band
of sword-wielding stink bags to attack
and kill the Pirates but the Bandit Bros
are so outmatched that Ben Beckman is
able to take them all out with the butt
of his rifle in mere seconds why would
he even have to shoot them when he can
just play baseball with their skulls
Luffy and the other townspeople can't
believe how strong just one member of
shanks's crew actually is and higuma
finally realizes that he doesn't stand a
chance against the red-haired gang
instead of staying to fight he lets one
rip or drops a smoke bomb or something
and then uses the diversion to grab
Luffy and Escape before the Pirates can
smack that stupid goatee off his face
higuma then takes Luffy out to sea on a
small boat and he brags about his
brilliant plan to hide out at Sea which
is the last place that anyone would look
for a mountain Bandit after bragging
that he already killed 56 people who
made him mad he casually kicks Luffy out
of the boat and into the sea higuma just
laughs at Luffy who is unable to swim
and who is about to drown right in front
of him but before Luffy even has a
chance to drown a giant sea monster
appears behind higuma and swallows him
whole right along with his boat and
while that's some good karma right there
Luffy is still in trouble because he's
still drowning what's more the sea
monster is planning to eat him next that
is exactly when Big Daddy Shanks steps
up to the plate yet again he swims up to
Luffy and moves him out of Harm's Way
before the monster can eat him he then
just mean mugs the Beast and tells him
to get out of here the giant monster
makes eye contact with shanks instantly
wets himself and speeds away in the
other direction now there are a lot of
fan theories about why the monster
became so terrified when Shanks looked
at it most people believe that this was
our first preview of someone using
conquerors hockey but we can't forget
that the monster just ate higuma so we
can't rule out the possibility that the
toxic Flames produced by his body gave
the monster sudden and explosive
diarrhea either way Luffy is now safe
but our boy is still crying shank smiles
and thanks Luffy for standing up for him
against the bandits but here's the thing
while Shanks is smiling and acting like
nothing happened both Luffy and us the
readers realize that Shanks just lost
his left arm when he swam up to Luffy
and moved him out of Harm's Way Shanks
got too close to the sea monster and the
Beast managed to bite off his arm just
below the shoulder and when Luffy points
out to Shanks that he's missing an arm
he simply responds with it's a small
price to pay okay on arm I'm glad you're
okay now while this is of course an
iconic moment that cements big daddy
Shanks as an absolute Giga Chad this
moment also marks the beginning of oda's
problems with shanks's character
problems which might come back to haunt
him in the final Saga of the story I'll
come back to this in a little bit
because we still got a few things to
wrap up before I get back to oda's
Shanks problem after Shanks saves
Luffy's life in such epic fashion Luffy
vows to one day become a great pirate
just like him Shanks becomes the
ultimate role model for Luffy and the
primary Father Figure in his life
despite the fact that both his father
and grandfather are very much alive
before Shanks departs from fuchsia
Village Luffy vows to one day become the
pirate king and Shanks decides to give
Luffy his Straw Hat the same straw hat
that he inherited from former pirate
king Goldie Roger Shanks makes Luffy
promise to give the hat back when you
becomes a great pirate and Shanks
privately admits to Beckman that Luffy
acts just like he did when he was a kid
once again I'll come back to the straw
hat later because that's another thing
that Oda will have some issues with
Luffy's own pirate adventure begins 10
years later now wearing the iconic straw
hat for which he would become known and
which will become his most recognizable
symbol and the most recognizable symbol
in all of one piece Luffy starts things
off with a bang as he uses gum gum
pistol to absolutely obliterate the same
sea monster that had attacked him 10
years earlier and as Luffy's Adventure
begins shanks's Legend only continues to
grow throughout the world only six years
after leaving fuchsia Village Shanks
becomes a Yanko one of the four Emperors
of the sea meaning that he is one of the
four most powerful pirates in the entire
world Shanks spent his days being a
Legendary Pirate hanging out with his
rival the world's strongest swordsman
mihawk warning people about how
dangerous Blackbeard is and keeping tabs
on Luffy's progress following the
Annie's Lobby incident Shanks confronts
Whitebeard aboard his own ship and
casually pimp slaps most of whitebeard's
crew with his conquerors hockey and not
only does Shanks cross swords with the
legendary Whitebeard to the point that
the very clouds in the sky split apart
under the force of their Clash but
Shanks has the sheer audacity to do it
while wearing the kind of pants that
you'd see on a guy who's vaping in a
Walmart parking lot I'm serious only
Shanks can pull off wearing those
second-hand Surfer pants while still
being one of the most respected people
in the world in fact Shanks has so much
power and respect that he was able to
stop kaido another Yanko and the world's
strongest creature from attacking
Whitebeard right before the Paramount
War he was also able to cruise into
Marine Ford save Kobe from Akainu and
then single-handedly stopped the war by
stating that anyone who wishes to
continue to fight we'll have to fight
him and his crew first all of the
factions on Marine Ford at that time
decided to back off rather than risking
a fight with Shanks including the
Marines the Whitebeard Pirates and the
Blackbeard Pirates Now by this point we
all got the message Big Daddy Shanks is
an absolute Beast a quintessential Giga
chat that we all simp for even though he
only shows up like once or twice every
few hundred chapters and Oda could have
stopped here and no one would have
questioned shanks's credentials but Oda
kept going and he continued to raise the
bar for Shanks as power level and
prestige in the eyes of the reader
Shanks is so respected that even the
gorosei are willing to Grant him a
private audience inside Pangea Castle
despite the fact that he is one of the
most Wanted pirates in the world some of
this might have to do with the fact that
he is probably a member of a prominent
World Noble family who had been on God
valley during the god Valley incident a
family by the name of vigorland but even
still the fact that a notorious
pirate-like Shanks one of the yonko can
just stroll into marijua and chat with
the gorosei is unheard of and then we
have wano and the absolutely staggering
red line-sized L that Shanks delivers to
Green Bull from miles away as Greenville
runs away faster than yasap runs from
fatherhood Shanks acknowledges that
Luffy has become a great pirate and that
it is finally time to go after the one
piece I mean that makes sense right
Luffy and his allies just took down two
yonko in a single fight Luffy himself
has just been named to the position of
yonko he is one of the four greatest
pirate captains in the world so if there
was ever a time for Shanks to finally
reunite with Luffy and fulfill the
promise that they made to each other 12
years ago or 25 years ago in real world
time then now is that time even members
of Shanks as crew want to disembark and
see Luffy again well not that deadbeat
yasop but lucky room and others clearly
do want the reunion to happen now and
yet Shanks says no even though this is
clearly the time to reunite with Luffy
and even though Oda has definitely kept
us waiting long enough Shanks still says
no and why does he say no because
bartolomeo went into shanks's territory
and burned some Flags or something so
shank says that he has to take care of
that first bro really really you haven't
seen Luffy in 12 years you're right here
in wano at the same time as him he's
clearly become a great pirate
ayanko and you won't go meet him because
of freaking bartolomeo don't get me
wrong I love my boy bartolomeo but he's
literally a Luffy simp if Luffy told him
to stand down and make peace with Shanks
he would do it immediately like think
about it tuyanko just fell the world is
in chaos countries are rebelling against
the world government the world
government is scrambling to respond to
all of this the one piece is ripe for
the taking is this really the right
moment for Shanks to be wasting time
with bartolomeo it just doesn't make
sense and that brings us to the big
problem with Shanks why put the reunion
off any longer what more could Luffy
possibly do to earn Shanks as respect it
feels like the only reason why the
reunion didn't happen is because it
isn't convenient for the plot regardless
of what the characters themselves may
want to do Oda seems to have backed
himself into a corner with shanks's
character and this is now affecting the
final Saga of the story I heard a lot of
people say that the reason why Luffy and
Shanks couldn't meet yet is because
Luffy promised to give Shanks his hat
back and since the straw hat has become
such an iconic symbol for Luffy Oda
doesn't want Shang things to take it but
Shanks could always just say keep the
Hat I'm betting the Hat on the Next
Generation or some other Shanks thing to
say and that's it if the Hat was the
only thing preventing two characters who
want to reunite from reuniting then that
is the definition of plot convenience
the characters are not behaving in the
way they should based on everything we
know about them just because that is
what's convenient for the plot so let's
hope it's not just about the Hat I think
that the real issue is probably
Blackbeard who has a long history with
Shanks I mean both Shanks and Luffy have
a score to settle with teach but Shanks
has known him since they were kids teach
was the one who gave Shanks that scar on
his face and Shanks has been warning
everyone for years about the danger that
Blackbeard poses to the entire world
it's possible that Oda wants Shanks to
have his epic confrontation with
Blackbeard first rather than have both
Shanks and Luffy face him together
because how overpowered would Shanks and
gear 5 Luffy B if they combine their
forces and their Crews and that begs the
question how will the battle between
Shanks and Blackbeard end if Shanks is
the one who takes down Blackbeard then
Luffy won't get the climactic
satisfaction of avenging Ace's defeat
for himself but if Blackbeard beats
Shanks then does that mean that Shanks
could die before his long-awaited
reunion with Luffy this is oda's biggest
predicament he's built up both Shanks
and Blackbeard as absolutely overpowered
monsters and if the two of them were to
engage in serious combat someone is
likely to die Shonen series have a long
tradition of killing off major Mentor
characters in order to further Advance
the development of the protagonist and
in some ways killing off Shanks would be
a powerful way to bring the new
generation to the Forefront and this
tragedy would force Luffy to grow and
progress as a character Luffy would then
keep the straw hat forever and he would
ultimately avenge his mentor Shanks by
one day taking down Blackbeard but the
problem with this is that we all
freaking love Shanks he's not just
admired by Luffy he is a fan favorite
for all the readers of the manga he is
so powerful that he can scare off an
admiral from miles away he is respected
and feared by the entire world including
the leaders of the world government so
how do you kill off a character like
Shanks despite only appearing in like 20
out of the well over a thousand chapters
Oda made Shanks such a badass Legend and
such a fan favorite that he's written
himself into a bit of a corner he
clearly doesn't want Shanks and Luffy to
meet just yet but if he was planning to
kill Shanks off as a way for Luffy to
grow he will have a very hard time going
through with it now just imagine the fan
reaction to the potential death of
Shanks if you think mha shippers are bad
on Twitter you have no idea what Shanks
Sims are capable of and I say that as a
proud Shanks simp myself I'm planning to
do a whole video on the fight between
Shanks and Blackbeard and which one of
them is stronger so if that's something
you're interested in don't forget to
subscribe we also have to look back to
that incident in chapter one when Shanks
lost an arm while protecting Luffy from
the sea monster knowing what we know now
about shanks's power a lot of people
believe that Shanks losing his arm just
didn't make sense in that situation he
should have been able to deal with that
sea monster easily and this discrepancy
speaks to the fact that Shanks ended up
being a lot stronger than Oda had meant
for him to become originally within the
few chapters that he actually appears
Oda has done a phenomenal job of making
Shanks an incredibly overpowered fan
favorite character but that very success
could be messing with his initial plan
for the final Arc of the story in many
ways Shanks is the Big Daddy of One
Piece not only is he a father figure to
Luffy and Utah he is probably the
biological father of machino's kid
because come on why else was he hanging
out at that random bar for over a year
my man is one of the most Wanted pirates
in the world he literally just robbed
the world government and then he just
happens to casually hang out in a bar
inside the hometown of marine vice
admiral GARP Shanks is no dummy he
doesn't take such stupid risks lightly
but he just couldn't resist those Makino
Mommy milkers I know this ship isn't
Canon but like dude trust me for Luffy
and for all of us one piece fans Shanks
is like the dad who goes out for
cigarettes and never comes back but you
still keep hearing about all the cool
things that he does with his other
family he is a living legend he is the
man who started it all at least as far
as Luffy's concerned he's got that red
Air Force energy and we can't wait to
see what he's going to do next the
biggest problem that Oda has with Shanks
is that as a sidekick character and the
kind of Mentor character that is often
killed off and Shonen he is just too
damn strong too damn cool and too damn
popular among the fan base I mean I'd
rather see both Ace and Jiraiya brought
back to life and then murdered Again by
Peach beard then see anything happen to
my boy Shanks do you guys agree hit me
up in the comments if you are interested
in how strong Shanks really is at this
point in the story click on this video
right now it's on screen and it's also
the first link down in the description